[Música]
muito bom dia a todos
só duas palavrinhas agradecer o convite
que foi feito pra fazer parte deste
primeiro evento x por isso é uma honra
pra mim
embora a minha onda seja cantar fado
vou fazer tudo que estiver ao meu
alcance para a crise alguém saia bem em
poema que foi escrito também por nós
antónio ribeiro
[Música]
a insight
i
robert deixa com um vínculo de amor
ora news era um coração que anuncia a
reação me viver ir e voltar a amar a
vida
acreditar deixam estão sós com o mundo
william aos nossos pés do senhor e
o chifre
viver ou obriga nos a descobrir
enfim mudar a vida ver de novo né brigar
com os olhos de criança brincando
o mundo vai virando e não estamos fora
mas ao cair procura e encontrar
a procurar ao
tô
o velório na vida ela não tem limite
foi da divena e hostil e nos prometeu
que aluga prado a vida surita
[Música]
o porto
maruschka
[Música]
ah
o lula
[Música]
[Aplausos]